momo c'est ce personnage un visage me
oiseaux 1000 femmes
une sculpture produite par un atelier
d'effets spéciaux mais rien de plus
effrayant une identité jamais dévoilées
pourtant son pouvoir terrifie
massa a été traumatisée par le mode
challenge pendant une semaine
l'arrivée de la tête voulait pas aller
sur son téléphone
elle a été tournée et franchement j'ai
déjà regardé des gens qui le faisait
mais je n'ai jamais fait pourquoi parce
que je ne veux pas mon mieux moore est
pas un hacker il contacte ses pourra via
whatsapp et propose de jouir des défis
troublant aussi viraux que macabre
comme cet adolescent retrouvé pendu au
domicile de ses parents en bretagne
dimanche dernier quand vous êtes sur
what's app vous envoyez votre fichier
photo brut avec toutes les informations
qu'ils l'intègrent et notamment quand
vous ferez ne prenez une photo assez
fier avec un téléphone portable la photo
est géolocalisé adresse numéro de
téléphone votre intimité dévoilée
récupéré par des hackers jusqu'aux
moindres détails comme la fleur de votre
lit des moyens de chantage les autorités
sensibilise les jeunes au cyber
harcèlement
on a créé une plateforme qui s'appelle
pharos où les parents voire les
adolescents et les enfants peuvent nous
faire remonter tout fait pour lequel il
aurait été victime à travers internet
ce soit des escroqueries du
cyberharcèlement détournement d'image
des pare feux peuvent être installées
sur les téléphones pour rester vigilant
de quoi tenir momo hors de votre
domicile car aujourd'hui il tente de
nombreux foyers dans le monde